[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'elle a comme défaut du
train n'a pas les bonnes cuisinières ça
compte mais je pense que c'est pareil
pour femmes les uns les autres ma faim
quand vous en vue de proposer autant
s'amuser pour initiés entre à oui parce
que la fin va rester à la maison a fait
le ménage
il s'est produit à lescar et qu'elle est
et lady ou la regarder faire non mais je
vais déjà le marché nous sommes dit ce
n'est pas moi
pourquoi ça vous plaît de vous retrouver
l'élite est difficile de s'entendre
continuellement avec des choix vous
voyez
une femme simplement tout ça comme ça on
évite de parler des femmes pourquoi
parce que ce n'est pas mon ami éviter ça
est encore vieux copains issus de sports
de boules alors on évite les questions
politiques de femmes pendant que les
hommes se reposent des femmes les femmes
s'occupent des hommes tendrement
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas le choix par la
cuisine à faire le linge lavé l'homme se
garde de se faire oublier et le toute
façon il n'est pas question de l'oublier
l'homme cependant qu'elle soit pauvre ou
riche qu'elle travaille pour eux ou
qu'elles s'apprêtent pour eux il y à
entrer ce que font toutes les femmes anr
semblables ce qu'elles font ils le font
non pas en cachette mais volontiers
santé - ou devant d'autres femmes pour
les hommes loin 10 ans
on y pense en guerre quand nous leur
reprochons par exemple cette frivolité
grave qu'il ait fait ce livre est
longuement aux outils ni aux mains qui
les perfection
[Musique]
avec la même patience l'application la
femme se mêlent aux travaux que les
mondes inventés
c'est toujours pour lui quel travail
mais en même temps c'est pour la société
tout entière est elle-même les travaux
d'électronique ou de laboratoire ces
travaux qui demandent des mânes
couturière elles les font mieux que les
hommes elles le savent on a besoin
d'elle et plus seulement la maison
certaines salles ne compte qu'un ou deux
spécimens mâles des contremaîtres comme
ceux que nous interroger personnellement
je préfèrerais commandés à des hommes
je préfère
on commandait les armes
les hommes sont pas rancuniers
deux heures après il se finit tandis
qu'une femme ça continue de s'accumuler
dans les semaines et des semaines
comment est ce que vous voulez est il
mort 2
on
dans certains corps plutôt sèchement
sèchement et ce but on disant vexant la
personne que
d'ailleurs une femme
bien souvent en caisse
- bien qu'aucun homme c'est pour ça que
j'ai fréquemment on trouve une femme qui
est en larmes
il pleure qu elle égalé
parce qu'on lui a fait une réflexion
alors après on est toujours le premier
embêté parce que c'est ça ce rapport sur
le travail
j'avais l'impression que vous leur
répondre mais plus sèchement parce que
ce sont des femmes oui parce que ça ça
porte davantage celui de se conduire
plus sévèrement
oui aussi vous le pensez je ne pense pas
non parce que les
les femmes comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on des raisons d'énervement qui
qu'on va arriver à comprendre une
question de psychologie les femmes
réagissent différemment suivant
l'observation pour leur père est ce
qu'elle se conduisent avec coquetterie
il a dit non non non non
elle essaye toujours mais ne faut pas se
laisser prendre au jeu il fallait d'une
table ce que vous voyez en sorte
imaginons que au lieu d'être chef
d'equipe comme vous l'avez actuellement
soyez quelque part dans cette chaîne
derrière qui évite maintenant et que à
votre place et une femme qui vous
recommande ce que vous vous sentiriez
blessés non pas 6 il si elle fait son
travail comme il faut correctement et
avait aucune raison qu ils vont ensemble
et c'est parce que c'est une femme joue
comme vous je ne pense pas que je
l'accepterai pourquoi de par mon
caractère
et vous j'ai déjà eu antérieurement
l'occasion d'être dirigé par une femme
et
il faut l'admettre que j'étais très bien
dirigés et que femme lorsqu'elle connaît
son métier ou tout au moins à ce qui lui
est alloué à faire dans une entreprise
est aussi valable car l'homme
pourquoi vous ne supporteriez pas il
disons que l'amour propre masculin sera
blessé
[Musique]
les femmes qui travaillent à ces
machines deux étages en dessous font de
travail auxquels la plupart des hommes
en france n'accepte plus de ce livre
elles sont sans qualification
professionnelle hors de ce travail il
n'y a rien il faut emboutir huit heures
par jour à longueur d'année les chaînes
de sécurité fixé leur poignet leurs tirs
les bras en arrière au cas où elles sont
virés d'enlever leurs mains dans ce
travail
on ne peut pas tout le temps penser à ce
qu'on fait
[Musique]
est ce qu'on pensait que c'est mieux
qu'une travail ne travaille pas mieux
qu'une femme ne travaille pas
grâce à la maison elle reste à la maison
vous je suis de cet avis également
je pensais que vous grattez la maison
absolument pourquoi parce que ça lui
permet déjà de leur rendre la vie plus
agréable à son mari parce que au lieu de
faire un certain nombre de choses
ensemble soir lorsque l'homme lui
rentrent à la maison déjà c'est une vie
familiale plus d'1 m parce que tout est
fait
la journée se termine tout calmement je
crois que la matinée se termine
la sortie pour un homme c'est le signe
qui en a fini avec sa journée pour une
femme la sortie des usines ou d'ateliers
ou de bureau ça veut dire la liberté de
commencer le travail qu'il a commencé
car une autre journée latin à la maison
au plus tôt la deuxième partie d'une
journée entreprises le matin et
interrompues par le travail à
l'extérieur là le visage fatigué les
yeux lourd à quel moment de la journée
ça l'après-midi le matin la maison du
goût de travail 4,9 ont cédé la maison
ah oui bon très complaisante en ruine
pleinement personne et l'on raconté
l'histoire quoi va pas bien joué une
fois tout ça
kehal temps ci annonce sa maman arrête
pas beaucoup joué je préfère faire sans
elles pas faire travailler à trouillas
quoi et bien un ou deux or elle est
enfermée ans vanessa réduit et
la maison elle fait tout ce qu'est ce
qu'on va faire quoi à maera comment les
vêtements a fait la vaisselle mais la
table quelquefois moi qui l'a même enfin
le plus souvent c c est le papa oui il
faut qu'elle fasse touchera tout le
travail qu'elle apparaissait à part la
journée le soir
les mères de famille s'est fatigué
chacun si ça le professeur avec qui nous
bavardions dans cette clinique
d'accouchement et c'est de connaître les
femmes en vivant auprès des 15 heures
par jour depuis 18 ans se présente
derrière accouché s'est passé quand le
dernier à coucher ça s'est passé il ya
quelques heures
comment ça s'est passé très bien qui est
rajeuni le jeu par son nom d'une toute
jeune femme qui a 20 ans et qui a sorti
un enfant de 3 kg 750 je dois dire avec
le sourire sur le visage ce qui était
très plaisant à voir est très séduisant
pour nous et pour toute l'équipe
si l'on convient enfin son premier
enfant est ce qu'elles sont pour elles
sont merveilleuses
je dirais même peut-être qu'elles sont
plus courageuse que les hommes les
jeunes accouchées sont souvent des
femmes palme est séduisante
coiffées et maquillées comme si la
beauté était vraiment le premier devoir
d'une femme là dessus tout le monde est
d'accord
[Musique]